bonjour nature je pense que les gens y
viennent parce que c'est la façon que
sont accueillis tout est un petit peu
tellement et personnalisé aujourd'hui un
peu quand tu rentres un endroit pour le
salut sophie commence à vous les gens
l'oif aux oies à m'appeler par mon nom
et dont elle a divorcé luis bergeron
avait 40 ans trois enfants mais pas de
diplôme lee métier elle devient
cordonnière sur un coup de tête
quand j'ai acheté en 2001 les gens de
téléphone
avantium qui ne supportait indie ben
voyons donc les gens jettent trop
à l'époque c'était un métier en voie de
disparition mais l'éveil écologique et
l'effet greta tim berg ravive les
commerces de réparation greta l aide
énormément la cause
ça c'est sûr ça le conscientiser les
gens sensibiliser les gens parce que
j'ai remarqué effectivement depuis
depuis quelques mois effectivement là la
hausse la vague effectuée les sablés
pour luis bergeron réparer un soulier
c'est un art une passion le côté
artisanal le côté créatif celui-ci lost
monsieur l'oeil un handicap t mais quand
qui vient me voir c'est comme un trophée
pour moitié lui quand qu'arrive la pizza
au walo is it a aidé à corriger ma
démarche ou un bain laisse mon dieu que
ça me fait chaud au coeur
bien plus que le montant d'argent pour
les deux ça serait 25 dollars le talent
est là avec sa une comme d'asnières est
ce que c'est la première fois première
fois mes jetons solde von goethe et je
me fais tu es vraiment à bout de bras
pendant quelques années pour que
j'arrive à faire mes preuves qui leur
montrer qu'une femme était capable
l'accord donne fière et par aussi des
sacs gaz est bon abri tempo et parfois
les gens meurtris la l'idéal ça va bien
elle connaît les noms des clients et
leur histoire
il y en a une qui est venu un j'ai
demandé comment elle et son fils si
violent que ça c'est cette mémoire aussi
d'avoir qui est précieuse parce que
c'est ce qui donne un sens à ton rapport
avec la clientèle quand tu te rappelles
qu'est ce que t'en on dit vraiment la
donne un sens ça donne d'humanisme c'est
accréditer un gain de wendel sur 6
heures je peux dire que je peux donner
au moins une heure et quart j'aimerais
que mon monde
cinq minutes avec un 10 minutes avec
l'ancien chef berçante pourra rien rozès
surfant excuses ils y sont presque plus
neuf que cathy zacate a fait un peu
d'amour c'est tout ce que j - moi là je
suis une grosse boule d'amour qui reçoit
de l'amour puis si je peux en de nice
parce que j'en reçois autant montpellier
en france en guadeloupe ça c'est un
autre cliente si clients n'oublie pas la
cordonnière même quand ils sont en
vacances
celle ci l'a remercié d'avoir rendu ses
souliers de mariée plus confortable
grâce à toi j'ai pu danser avec mon
prince jusqu'aux petites heures du matin
dans un confort enchanté merci petite
fée des souliers
si bas c'est comme ça qu'on m'appelle
l'actif et des souliers
c'est un choix que j'ai fait comme ça
dans ma vie puisse et des plus beaux
cadeaux je me suis offert entre autres
avec mes trois enfants qui m'ont chambre
[Musique]